try to make a point as best I can not to
endorse too much in primaries but my
favorite thing about this field is that
right now of the current and prospective
candidates
think most of them have endorsed my
books that's the main thing that matters
to me right now about the field Nikki
Mike Pompeo Senator Cruz I think there
was a there's one more endorsed uh
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds which is available now number one
National bestseller thank you very much
uh president Trump endorsed my first
book reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide also available right
now I think I'm missing one or two uh in
any case though this is really really
important this is the main thing forget
about the economy forget about
immigration forget about foreign policy
the main thing is right now we have a
field that is shaping up where uh a huge
number of them have a really really
great taste in books